Two days before the Obama administration
ended, its Department of Education
released a report showing the
administration's most expensive
education initiative had failed – badly.
The school turnaround program was meant
to dramatically improve the nation's
lowest performing schools. The Obama team
sent billions of dollars to the
struggling districts running the
struggling schools.
This is the foundation of countless
previous local, state, and federal school
turnaround efforts. This final report
found that the schools that got the
money, when compared to similar schools
that didn't get the money, saw no
improvement in test scores, in high
school graduation rates, or college
attendance. None.
Yes, billions of taxpayer dollars were
squandered, but more importantly, millions
of low-income kids are still assigned to
persistently underperforming schools. Now
the new federal education law encourages
states to use new approaches to this
problem, and the Trump administration is
pushing school choice. But whatever we do,
remember: The future of millions of
disadvantaged kids is at stake here.
Great schools and great educators can do
so much. We just have to do something differently.
To learn more about my take on
education reform, check the links in the
description below. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like AEI scholars to
cover in 60 seconds.